Muy buenas tardes pues ya todo este
cortejo de manifestación que salió desde
la Plaza de la ópera está llegando aquí
a la Plaza de la bastilla donde se han
presentado uno que otro disturbio
ustedes pueden ver Tal vez un poco aquí
a mis espaldas como hay Estos son gases
lacrimógenos y también a varias canecas
que han sido incendiadas por algunos
manifestantes especialmente estos
jóvenes encapuchados de Ultra izquierda
y Ultra derecha pero por lo general la
situación ha sido más bastante Tranquila
aquí en París también hay algunos
reportes de la situación de pronto De
pronto un poco de tensión en la ciudad
de red en donde la puerta de un banco
Pues fue reventada con una explosión y
también algunos carros que resultaron
incendiados por ahora según los
sindicatos habría unas cuatrocientas mil
personas las que habrían manifestado tan
solo aquí en París pero el Ministerio
del interior divide esa cifra
prácticamente por diez siempre se dan
digamos estas dos interpretaciones en
cuanto a las cifras de participación
pero sí es digamos muy cercano a lo que
se esperaba el día de hoy de que la
manifestación Pues en todo el país A
pesar de los doscientos puntos de
manifestación que pues se tenían
previstos no fuera tan masiva como en
otras ocasiones
y Natalia precisamente como como
decíamos no estas movilizaciones tienen
lugar en un día clave y es que como
avanzábamos mañana el consejo
constitucional de Francia va a fallar
sobre si esta ley es constitucional o no
Qué expectativas hay y qué puntos del
texto serían susceptibles de ser
inconstitucionales
efectivamente Pues hay muchísima
expectativa en cuanto a esto De hecho
toda esta manifestación pasó muy cerca
de la Sede del Consejo constitucional de
alguna manera como diciéndoles estamos
esperando lo que ustedes van a fallar el
día de mañana por ahora digamos que
algunos expertos constitucionalistas no
creen que el consejo vaya a decir que
todo el contenido de de este de este
texto es anticonstitucional pero sí Hay
posibilidad de que haya algunos apartes
más que todo más ahí digamos que en
algunos artículos precisos Es sobre todo
en la manera el hecho de que se haya
hecho esto a través de una ley de
finanzas sino sea una ley digamos que
sea en Sí sola sobre la sobre la reforma
pensional Así que ese puede ser uno de
los puntos y el otro también es digamos
más bien en el método el hecho de haber
utilizado algunos artículos de la
constitución para que todos los debates
sean mucho más rápidos Así que esto es
digamos de los puntos que bien algunos
expertos en esta materia consideran que
podrían entrar dentro de lo no
exsequible con respecto a esta con
respecto a esta ley de la Reforma
pensional que forma parte de una ley
digamos de finanzas rectificativas y ahí
puede estar digamos ese pequeño bemol
que puede darle digamos alas En todo
caso a quienes están en contra de esta
reforma esperando De todas maneras Pues
que en algún momento el gobierno pueda
dar a marcha de marcha atrás